pau n'est pas mixte en fait d'autant
plus mal aux filles les filles ou
garçons élevés quand on lit un grand
après qu'on s'entend mal épines on se
dit alors moi je dis qu e les garçons
les filles ont les par l on est égal je
vois pas pourquoi comment je sais par
red hat on t'as plus souvent les
égard soit parce que les films ne trouve
pas on dirait que c'est chouchoute
il exagère un peu parce que monsieur ado
qui l'a jamais tapé c'est plutôt de la
câlinerie ce trou enfin c'est plutôt de
la plaisanterie
parce que plus nous tient plutôt les
oreilles le lait mais nous donne pas de
peur de rien dit comme ça la mixité
c'est bien parce que dans la vie les
garçons et les filles sont toujours
ensemble au travail on n'a pas trop en
général c'est un garçon qu'on se marie
avec un gars oh et puis en vidéo
on vit presque toujours avec des garçons
les filles en leur leurs opinions et
leurs idées mais les garçons aussi alors
ça permet de discuter ensemble et pas
avoir le même avis chez les filles
partent même travaillant je serai très
mou est lui jetez moi très bien content
moi je trouve qu'il n'ya pas de raison
de nous séparer
comment des filles parce que à l'école
maternelle on est ensemble et puis d'un
seul coup on se quitte et au lycée on se
retrouve maintenant alors il n'y a pas
de raison que dans comment à l'école on
se quitte
[Musique]